Traduttore: Silvia Forato
Revisore: Federico Sangati
In una città qualunque,
sono le sette di mattina
di un giorno qualunque,
in un mese qualunque,
voi siete su un bus
un bus qualunque
E state andando in ufficio
un ufficio qualunque
No signora, non scendo alla prossima
Ecco, il vostro cellulare
inizia già a vibrare
delle prime notifiche della giornata
delle notifiche qualunque
ma notifiche che comunque
non potete ignorare
siete proprio lì a rispondere
ai vostri primi messaggi della giornata
dei messaggi qualunque
quando il bus frena di colpo
qualcuno vi urta e si scusa
scendete alla vostra fermata
e andate al solito edicolante
un edicolante qualunque
a comprare il vostro quotidiano preferito
un quotidiano qualunque.
ma ecco che una qualunque
ordinaria giornata
sta per trasformarsi in un momento
che vostro malgrado
difficilmente dimenticherete
mettete mano al portafogli
e non lo trovate
eppure eravate così convinti
di averlo portato con voi
messo al sicuro nella vostra tasca
ed è là che mi viene in mente
quel signore distinto
che dopo avervi urtato si è scusato
un signore distinto qualunque
Signori sono Tiziano Grigioni
e sono uno di quelli
che hanno deciso di fare del vostro
portafogli, il proprio stipendio
sì esatto signora,
sono un borseggiatore
ma non un borseggiatore qualunque
no sono un borseggiatore da palcoscenico
questo significa che sul palco
rubo oggetti dalle tasche delle persone
ma il mio ego si nutre
talmente tanto di applausi
da impormi di farmi scoprire subito
A proposito di furti e di applausi
Ve ne ho appena rubato uno
Grazie
La mia disciplina in gergo è definita
pickpocketing
ed è un'arte decisamente molto simile
all'illusionismo
Ecco ma com'è possibile
che un tizio tanto assurdo
conciato come me
voglio dire avete visto che barba
Riesca a mettervi le mani in tasca
ed a sottrarvi a vostra insaputa
i vostri effetti personali
Grazie a quella che gli americani
definiscono misdirection
il depistaggio mentale,
l'arte vera e propria di indirizzare
e condizionare l'attenzione degli
spettatori
è quindi possibile davvero controllare
l'attenzione dell'essere umano
al punto da prevederne i propri
atteggiamenti in base ai nostri stimoli
la risposta è sì, è possibile
e non bisogna di certo essere
un supereroe di stanley per farlo
Nonostante io nonostante io assomigli a
un cartone animato
misdirection
si è ovvio non esiste un pulsante on off
in grado di attivare o disattivare
la nostra sorveglianza mentale
eppure la miss direction è
sotto gli occhi di tutti costantemente
tutti voi seduti in platea, anch'io,
ne siamo vittime inconsapevoli
ci si distrae di continuo
Oddio ho un pelo bianco nella barba
e non ho nemmeno compiuto 30 anni
e passo le prossime due ore
davanti allo specchio
a vedere questo lento declino
da giovane ladro barbuto
alla copia più hipster di santa claus
Ci si distrae di continuo
anche per i motivi più futili
il problema, problema di tutti
è che siamo in questa epoca moderna
costantemente bersagliati da informazioni
come dardi, come frecce ci arrivano
Il guaio è che non riusciamo a
concentrarci né su uno né sull’altro
No, li riceviamo tutti e tutti assieme
a tal punto da non focalizzare
la nostra attenzione su quello
veramente importante
o comunque su quello che preferiamo
vi faccio un esempio, immaginate
per favore di vivere in un piccolo paesino
un piccolo paesino dove tutti vi conoscono
e tutti si conoscono
non avete a vostra disposizione
una grande varietà di intrattenimento
e i pochi libri della vostra biblioteca
privata li conoscete ormai a memoria
vita tranquilla no?
noiosa oserei dire
per un diabolik da esposizione come
il sottoscritto
Ecco, ora immaginate di vivere invece,
in una grande metropoli
in espansione come gotham city
Esatto alla città di batman
dove nessuno vi conosce
e ogni persona che incontrate è
un potenziale amico, nemico,amante
luoghi da visitare, pericoli da schivare
e da eludere
Ecco questa è la vostra mente
una città, una metropoli
in perenne espansione
24 ore su 24
anche durante le ore di sonno
tradotto nel concreto
quando chiamò sul palco uno spettatore
e tento di sottrargli il portafogli
e quant'altro la prima cosa che faccio
è constatare se nella tasca
ha qualche oggetto al di là
del portafogli
oh il caro amico mio
che bella giacca di opti tur
dopo posso chiederle dove l'ha comprata
ed ecco che l'attenzione dello
spettatore è sulla giacca
Anzi quasi compiaciuto, mi sta chiedendo
dove ho comprato questa giacca
mia moglie mi ha fatto i complimenti
anche lui mi stai facendo i complimenti
per questa superba giacca
quindi l'idea di farsi derubare è
totalmente fuori dai suoi schemi cognitivi
così come questi peli sono fuori
dalle mie ghiandole pilifere
amico mio ha con sé del denaro?
ed ecco che dalla giacca l'attenzione
passa al portafogli
non si rende però conto che con l'altra
mano gli ho appena rubato lo smartphone
dalla tasca
ecco questa sensazione di straniamento
non vi è familiare?
quante volte arrivate a fine giornata a
casa con questo senso di vuoto
magari vi eravate prefissati
degli obiettivi
e non gli avete portati a termine
Perché? perchè appunto vi siete lasciati
trascinare dagli eventi, dalle situazioni
non avete focalizzato la vostra attenzione
ma vi siete lasciati mettere barriere
dalle vostre distrazioni del quotidiano
ad esempio arrivate in ufficio e sulla
scrivania trovate già due postit gialli
Riccardo Rossi va richiamato e la ditta
qualcosa vuole un nuovo preventivo
accendete il pc e trovate sette mail
a cui rispondere
dovete rispondere subito
e poi ancora telefonate, news,
notifiche, comunicazioni
finalmente la pausa pranzo e cosa fate?
controllate facebook
quindi ancora notifiche, news
e comunicazioni
e ancora la ricetta vegana per la
carbonara
perché si esiste una carbonara vegana
l'ennesimo sacerdote che a messa canta
ricchi e poveri
l'amico, il vostro ex compagno di scuola
che vi invita al suo matrimonio in comune
con comunione di beni
mentre amico in comune
fa un post irritato
perché l'amico in comune
non l'ha invitato in comune al matrimonio
con comunione di beni
e ancora l’oroscopo
la 37esima copertina per lo stesso sempre
identico volume di harry potter
volo più hotel a zanzibar tutto compreso
350 euro hashtag ciaone
clicca qui per sapere come fare
e foto di gattini
a tutti piacciono le foto di gattini
signora
un vecchio vaso sulla tv un gatto bianco
con gli occhi blu
no il sacerdote che canta ricchi e poveri
com’è che faceva
ecco ovviamente passa la pausa pranzo
non avete dato neanche un morso
al vostro panino
si sta ragionando per eccessi,
questo è vero
ma anche una qualunque giornata tipo
può costellararsi di difficoltà,
di imprevisti, di disattenzione
io da giovane e millenni al quindi nato
a cavallo tra gli anni 90 e 2000
sono abituato o quantomeno
mi dichiaro abituato
a vivere, a nuotare in questo mare
frenetico che ogni giorno ci ci sovrasta
in realtà non è affatto così,
non è affatto così
tutti noi ci distraiamo,
io appunto in primis
perché nessuno, nessuno ci impone di
controllare le mail sette volte al minuto
nessuno ci vieta di di spegnere il wifi
per almeno una manciata di ore al giorno
Eppure il telefono squilla dling dlong
lo prendo e metto like alla foto
in cui sono stato taggato
soprattutto se nella foto ci sono gattini
è impossibile veramente farne a meno
è impossibile farne a meno
ma quindi quanto tempo noi
sottraiamo a noi stessi
perché di questo che si parla,
del tempo, la sensazione di vuoto
che provate a fine giornata
è la stessa sensazione di vuoto
che provano le vostre tasche dopo un
incontro truffaldino con il sottoscritto
ma ben più importante di uno smartphone
è l'oggetto della vostra mancanza
si signori sto parlando della moneta più
preziosa che tutti noi abbiamo: il tempo
a quanto ammonta quindi il tempo
che perdiamo?
secondo una ricerca di mercato del 2016
condotta da media x
che è un'agenzia di influencer
marketing statunitense
si stima che trascorriamo circa due ore
al giorno sui social
in particolare su youtube, facebook
e instagram
questo fa sì, facendo un rapido calcolo
che noi trascorriamo
sulle reti di comunicazione sociale
ben 5 anni e 4 mesi della nostra vita
considerando che almeno tre anni
li passo sicuramente a pettinarmi la barba
la scorta di sabbia nella clessidra
è effettivamente in esaurimento
5 anni e 4 mesi, amici miei, cinque anni
e quattro mesi
in 5 anni e 4 mesi potremmo andare
a piedi sulla grande muraglia cinese
avanti e indietro per tre volte e mezzo
in 5 anni e 4 mesi potremo andare
sulla luna 32 volte
in 5 anni e 4 mesi potremmo guardare
i Simpson, tutti gli episodi
puntate speciali incluse
215 volte: 5 anni e 4 mesi
il problema è che noi crediamo
di essere in una frenetica modernità
effettivamente siamo in una frenetica
modernità ma non è da incolpare gli altri
spesso ci ritroviamo a vedere noi
come non lo so, vittime di disattenzione
e mai come colpevoli di distrazione
sempre vittime, nonostante adesso,
se ci fate caso
le pubblicità che vedete in tv durano
un decimo di quelle
che passavano vent'anni fa
Perchè ormai la nostra soglia attentiva
è sempre più breve
Ed è la stessa cosa che faccio io quando
metto le mani nelle tasche delle persone
lavoro su questo
ecco, l'uomo da sempre è alla costante
ricerca di stimoli sensoriali
che vengono dall'esterno anche
involontariamente
pensate che già nel 1600 una persona
a caso
tale blaise pascal diceva che
il guaio dell'uomo che non riesce a
starsene tranquillo in una stanza da solo
e come dargli torto ma come soccombere
quindi a questa mancanza di tempo
come far sì che le nostre difese
d'attenzione siano muri di cemento armato
ecco a parer mio dovremmo intanto
saper discernere tutto ciò che è utile
e piacevole da ciò che è superfluo
come la birra al pub con gli amici
il sabato sera
o la vacanza con la vostra dolce metà
soprattutto se a zanzibar 350 euro
volo più hotel tutto compreso
e ovviamente quando sentite imparate
a riconoscere appunto le sensazioni
che sperimentate nella vostra testa
quando sentite di stare per distrarvi,
staccate, pausa 2- 5 minuti
e poi tornate al lavoro
questo farà sì che voi sarete sempre più
soddisfatti del vostro operato
e che possiate perseguire le vostre
passioni
ma come ricondurre tutto ciò all'arte
truffaldina dei furti da palcoscenico
signori ho parlato troppo c'è per caso
tra voi un volontario
mi hanno detto che lo staff del ted
ha scelto per me una vittima
una vittima che si presterà per
questo spettacolo
e che mi presterà questa volta senza punta
il contenuto delle sue tasche
dove sei?
eccolo qua un forte applauso per lui
grazie
ciao Tiziano come ti chiami ?
Francesco
un applauso per Francesco
eccolo qua Francesco meraviglioso
francesco sei già stato sul palco
no però ti vedo propenso alla scena
sei ben piantato
non è meraviglioso Francesco
ecco mi raccomando però è bene che tu
sia d'aiuto un secondo ok
ok meraviglioso in teatro Francesco
non si danno mai le spalle al pubblico
perciò guarda qua sorridi
un applauso per Francesco
di nuovo grazie mille Francesco
Francesco, Francesco immagina di stare
sul bus sì il bus degli hobbit
no Francesco il bus, meraviglioso
Francesco
ora tutte le persone sul bus
Francesco sono attente al contenuto
delle proprie tasche
e soprattutto il portafogli
hai con te un portafogli?
posso vederlo un secondo
o nel mentre Francesco
si può lasciare il bus per un momento
soltanto
signore e signori il ladro si appropinqua
del portafogli della vittima
il furto più veloce della storia
grazie
no Francesco, mi rendo conto
che davanti a questa platea ted insomma
questo è un pò una truffa nella truffa
no facciamo una dimostrazione più
veritiera
ok il portafogli al sicuro nella tua
tasca, meraviglioso
possiamo cominciare
ti chiedo appunto di prendere il bus,
di fare un passo avanti
ottimo Francesco
fammi controllare
stai bene sì,stai benissimo
questo è importante
le spalle tutto apposto ok Francesco
Francesco una cosa come fa il ladro ad
appropriarsi degli oggetti della vittima
mediante quello che è definito metodo dro
No che non c'entra nulla con
la California del Trentino
dro: distrazione reazione obiettivo
distrazione o che bella giacca haute
couture che ha francesco, posso vederla?
meraviglioso e qui adesso la sua
soglia d'attenzione è totalmente distante
dal fatto che voglio rubargli il
portafogli, assolutamente
reazione: francesco appunto pensa
ad altro non si rende conto
che sto controllando il contenuto
delle sue tasche interne
amici miei, obiettivo, il ladro si
appropria dell'oggetto della vittima
o almeno questo succederebbe se fossimo
sul bus, invece noi siamo sul palco
mi sembra scontato e brutto rubarti
le cose giustamente sul palco, giusto?
perfetto, signori questo vuol dire
che il metodo dro funziona
Francesco impegnato com'eri a pensare
al tuo portafogli non ti sei reso conto
che qualcos'altro ti manca:
il tuo cellulare
signori il cellulare di Francesco
un applauso
[Risate] ma signori francesco torna
pure qua dove scappi
manca qualcos'altro all'appello
il tuo portafogli
grazie mille Francesco
vieni qua, un inchino
vai Francesco, forza forte
come basta fai questo forte inchino
e vai pure
grazie mille Francesco
no Francesco dove vai?
una persona elegante come te
senza la cravatta
signore e signori per voi Francesco
e la sua cravatta
grazie mille Francesco puoi andare
Signori per oggi da Tiziano Grigioni il
vostro hipster trickster è davvero tutto
sono stato felicissimo di essere qui
di essere stato qui con voi
siete il pubblico migliore che abbia avuto
oggi
spero che il tempo da voi messo a
disposizione per questa performance
sia tempo che mi abbiate regalato
e non tempo che v’ho sottratto
Grazie